le premier enseignement de ces deux
études publiées ces derniers jours par
l'insee c'est que les pauvres sont de
plus en plus pauvre et qu'ils sont de
plus en plus nombreux les 10% de la
population qui gagne le mois ont
bénéficié en 2018 d'un niveau de vie 1,5
pour cent inférieur à celui de l'année
précédente soit 170 euros deux mois ils
vivent même avec près de 3% de moins qu
il y a dix ans et cette tendance à la
baisse concerne en fait les 30% des
français les moins bien lotis quant au
nombre de pauvres est bien il a continué
de croître en 2018 plus de 9,3 millions
de personnes vivaient avec moins de 60%
du revenu médian 14 8% de la population
du jamais vu depuis 1996 cette frange
des français subsistent avec moins que
le smic net et avec moins de 855 euros
pour près de cinq millions d'entre eux
alors pourquoi cette tendance et bien
selon les études de l'insee il y à la
crise financière de 2008 dont les plus
pauvres ont davantage souffert et qui
peine plus que les autres à s'en
remettre
mais il ya aussi et c'est plus récent
les effets de la politique fiscale
adoptée au début du quinquennat d'
emmanuel macron à commencer par la
baisse des allocations logement on peut
noter aussi la hausse de la csg ou le
gel des pensions qui a particulièrement
affecté les retraités dont le taux de
pauvreté a connu une hausse de 1,1 point
en 2018 soit cent soixante trois mille
personnes supplémentaires leur niveau de
vie médian a baissé de 430 euros cette
année là al'inverse les plus aisés eux
s'en sortent bien mieux et c'est là
aussi dû à la politique fiscale voulue
par le locataire de l'elysée selon
l'insee les plus riches ont pu compter
en 2018 sur les effets de deux mesures
gouvernementales premièrement la flat
tax jusqu'à 640 euros supplémentaires
sur l'année pour les 5 % les plus aisés
dont le niveau de vie a aussi augmenté
jusqu'à 840 euros grâce à la
transformation de l' isf en impôt sur la
fortune immobilière
alors bien entendu ces deux études ne
nous disaient
bien sûr l'état des finances des
français en 2019 ou en 2020 ce que l'on
observe tout de même c'est une tendance
à la hausse des inégalités et oui
l'avantagent avec le partage des
richesses c'est que certains peuvent
avoir les richesses et les autres le
partage